[Applause]
once again a funeral procession in
Baghdad for an individual killed by a US
air strike this time it was
wasi a commander and adviser of the
Iranian bagged group hisbah brigades the
US blames him for planning and
participating in attacks against its
forces in the region his assassination
has increased an already heightened anti
us sentiment
here we in the Islamic resistance will
respond at a suitable time and location
we won't forget the blood of our people
we'll confront the Americans and the
Zionist occupation in
Gaza we will take revenge not only
through counterattacks but also through
raising awareness of the culture of
resisting the American occupation and
pgy in the
region the mourar called on the Iraqi
Parliament to draft a mandate to expel
US troops this is the fourth us AR raay
targeting paramilitary Personnel in Iraq
within a month the Pentagon says they're
aimed at preventing more attacks on US
forces but with armed groups threatening
to escalate their resistance against the
US and its allies the scale of the
conflict could spread further across the
region the government here has
repeatedly stated these types of US air
strikes violate Iraq's sovereignty and
threaten to drag the country into a
circle of regional
conflict this particular us strike was
in response to last month's drone attack
by the Iranian bagged Islamic resistance
group that killed the three US soldiers
and injured dozens more the group blames
the US for supporting Israel's military
campaign in Gaza and has threatened to
increase its attacks until us and
Coalition forces withdraw from
Iraq mm Abdul Al jaaz
bdad make sure to subscribe be to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer